hello friends welcome to the last part
of the nc3 sideline
where we are going to deal with the move
d4
now amongst three reply d4 is the most
critical one and when we play the move
d5 white has three good choices
in one rapid game where my opponent was
2000 plus rated responded with the move
f3
which is in fact a good move
here i'm recommending that you should
capture the e4 pawn and now in the view
of
d4 pawn is hanging white response is
forced while it has to play the move d5
and afterwards we are going to play the
move knight to e5
knight to e5 create a nasty trap if your
opponent plays this a tracking looking
move that is queen to d4
then white can get into the big trouble
after the move e captures f3
the main reason is when white captured
the piece
black has this amazing stunner that is
f2 check kindly note king cannot capture
the pawn because of the knight folk so
king d1 looks obvious move afterwards
black will capture his piece back and
after rook captures
black has this
attacking move e6
and i think it's only black who is
having all the fun in this line
so that's why queen to d4 is not
possible at this point that means white
has to capture the pawn
afterwards i'm recommending that you
should put the knight immediately on the
g6
the idea is very simple we want to
undermine the white center as quickly as
possible
the game continues with the moon knight
to f3 and e5 is the move which not only
restrict white activity
but it will allow black to deal off his
all piece very freely
my opponent responded with the move
bishop to g5 pinning my knight i
responded with bishop to b4 pinning his
knight and then he exchanged his slight
square bishop
which is in fact his bad bishop and
plays the move queen to d3
so his idea is very clear you just want
to be remain flexible and depending on
the black responses he can go either
short or the long castle
well i immediately remove all the
possibility with the move bishop
captures knight
it's very obvious that queen cannot
capture the c3 so my opponent has to
forcefully capture with the b pawn
afterwards i responded with the move
knight to h5
now as we see in other lines if knight
to f4 has been allowed then black opted
in amazing position
so opponent understanding that he stop
it with the move g3
i responded with the move at 6 and he
drove his bishop back to the e3
now both side castle
well you can easily see the major
difference in terms of king security as
white king has some vehicle light square
around his territory
so i tried to exploit that immediately
with the move queen to g4
my opponent responded with the move rook
to b1
i hit his queen with the move knight to
f4 when queen placed on the c4 i
responded with the move b6
taking the c7 pawn will be very very
risky
so knowing that my opponent is pointed
with the move rope b to d1
i responded with the typical attacking
plan that is knight to h3 check king to
h1 and now the move f4
which at first sight looks very risky
especially when my opponents played the
move d6 jack king to h7 and now
d capture c7
but it's all good after the move rook to
c8 black doesn't have to worry about the
c7 point right now
it has his own attack going on the king
side
white responded here with the move a4 so
his idea is to undermine the pawn chain
but it's little bit late because my king
side activity coming into the picture
immediately after the move f4
after some calculation he captured my
pawn i captured with the knight and now
there's a checkmate on g1 so he captured
my dangerous knight and after some
thinking i capture with the rook
which at first it looks very very
dangerous after my opponent's next move
that is rook to d1 so idea is to
capturing the rook or maybe queen to ga
check
but trust me i have worked all this out
and i played a cold-blooded move that is
rogue captures f3 allowing this queen to
ga check
king to g6
i know i have to do a king dance but my
king will be very safe soon
so he continued with the move queen to
ea check
king to g5
queen captures e5 and now finally king
to h4 and the king is quite safe there
that means white has to deal with the
checkmate threat of rook captures f1
again after a long thinking he come out
with the only good move that is rook
back to the d1
but now the tasks become very very easy
i give you a few seconds can you
identify a move which will confirm black
victory
okay i hope you find this move that is
rook capture c7
i think he was in time trouble and he
immediately captured my rook which leads
to the disaster after the move order
rook captures rook rope captures rook
and now queen captures e4
which is unavoidable checkmate
so there was one model game which will
highlight the plants black can adopt
against the moon f3
the second move i want to consider is e
captures d5 afterwards
black has to certainly capture this pawn
and now as i have highlighted
white has three different choices
amongst them bishop to b5 is not a good
one once again the simple reason is
there will be a transposition of the
line which we have already look at it in
knight to f3 radiation where here black
will continue with the moon knight
captures knight
bishop captures knight
b capture c6 b capture c3 and now the
trademark move
queen to d5
if knight to f3 then bishop to g4 is a
very strong move
white will get another set of double
pawn so only independent move over here
is queen to f3
but this is actually a dubious move the
simple reason is
black can stop white to castle on the
king side with the move bishop to a6
and after the move bishop to a3
which looks like stopping black's
development but black bishop can develop
on other diagonals so that is g6
idea is to play bishop g7 and castle on
the king side
and in order to complete his development
the best move suggested by engine is
exchanging the queen which is obviously
a very good choice for the black
so straight away you can say this line
is not at all good for the white
the second move i want to consider is
knight to r3 well after this i'm
recommending that you should play the
move bishop to f5 and the planning is as
usual
so we want to play the move e6
bishop to e7 castle on the king side and
then at the right time look out for the
move c5
if white plays bishop d3 we can exchange
this bishop and then continue with our
plan so no issues with this
so the only independent move over here
is bishop to b5
well against this i'm recommending that
you should continue with the move e6
allowing the moon knight to e5
black has a very strong reply that is
knight capture c3
has to capture this knight and
afterwards we are going to play the move
queen to d5
attacking two spots
now in one blitz game my opponent come
out with this attracting looking move
that is
c4
but the problem is after queen catches
g2
rook to f1
and bishop to b4
white is busted
the simple reason is after bishop to d2
black has this lethal check that is
queen to e4
that will more or less stamp the victory
the game continues with the move queen
to e2 afterwards i capture the bishop
and after king recapture
i simply capture the c2 pawn
and
after a few moves white resign so it's
already a designable position
so c4 or a4 are not good at this point
the best move over here is bishop
capture knight afterwards we are
capturing with the b pawn and now white
has to castle on the king side
but if this is the best white can have
it then
black can easily dissolve his double
pawn via the order c5
a sample line can run like this if
bishop to a3 then the simplest is you
play the move bishop to d6 protecting
your bishop and the same time hitting
the knight so knight has to drop back to
the f3 afterwards we can simply get rid
of our weak pawns that is c captures d4
bishop captures bishop pawn captures and
pawn captures and rook to c8
it is only white who has to defend his
backward pawns and black will enjoy the
attacking
so that was about knight to f3 the third
move i can try is bishop to c4
but after this move if you want you can
go back to the line which i have
recommended earlier that is knight to b6
and bishop to f5
but especially against this setup i
think knight capture c3 is a very strong
move the simple reason is when white
recapture denied then you can play this
amazing move that is e5
obviously white cannot capture the pawn
so he has to complete his king side
development with the move knight to f3
afterwards we are going to capture the d
pawn and when white we capture we can
complete our king side peace development
with the move bishop to b4 check bishop
to d2 bishop captures bishop queen
captures
castle on the king's side
and
white cannot castle here
white has to play the d5
the problem with the move castle is
black can immediately respond with the
move bishop to g4
hitting the knight which is giving
protection to the d4 square
and if it's not defended then the fight
pawns will be double on the king side
so for example if queen to e3 then the
simplest is
bishop captures knight queen captures
knight and now queen catches d4 with a
clear pawn advantage and attacking
position
white has to respond here with the move
d5
afterwards we get a very comfortable
game with the mo order rook to e8 check
bishop to e2
knight to e5
castle on the king side and then very
simple is queen d6
rookie one and bishop to d7
even though it looks like the position
is equal but the problem with the white
position is it has a hanging pawn which
can be easily targeted so for example if
c4 then b6
then black can train is all piece to
attack these hanging pawns
so we can easily conclude over here that
amongst all these three move black can
obtain more than a comfortable game
so let's look at the most critical move
that is e5
well here black has to play the only
move that is knight to e4
and now once again white has four
different choices amongst them knight
catches e4 is the main move but let's
look at the sideline first
the first move i want to consider is
bishop to d3 which is a dubious move
the simple refrigeration is you can
capture this pawn and after the
following sequence that is knight
captures knight pawn captures bishop
captures bishop to f5
bishop captures
knight captures queen captures and rook
captures
yes the position is equal but i strongly
prefer black the simple reason is it has
already developed a two piece
and they spawn on e5 sometimes become a
very good target
now other moves white has is knight
moves so for example knight to e2 or
knight to f3
against this remember the golden rule
that if knight goes to the e2 then you
place your bishop on f5 and if the
knight goes to the f3 then you place
your bishop on the g4
and that way you get a very comfortable
game
okay let's see knight to e2 first if
knight g to e2
obviously we are going to play the move
bishop to f5 and the whole idea of
knight to e2 is to play the move f3 and
dislodging the knight
well no matter we are exchanging the
pair of knight and now we play the move
e6
now here white has to be very very
careful if white casually develop his
king side bishop for example bishop to
d3
then after queen to h4 check
g3 and queen catches d4
black obtain upon advantage
so the more normal move over here is
bishop to e3
afterwards we are straight away
undermining the spawn chain with the
move f6
this is a case of one of my rapid game
where my opponent responded with the
move he captures f6 i responded with the
move queen captures f6
he dealt off his king side piece with
the move bishop to b5 i played bishop to
d6 he castle on the king's side and i
did the same and we should stop over
here it's very easy to see that
not only black has these wonderful
bishops but it has an open f file where
if you look at white pieces they all
looks very clumsy this bishop is out of
the play so as this knight and what this
bishop is doing on e3 nothing
so black has a wonderful attacking
position
the third move i can try is knight to f3
but as usual we are going to play the
move bishop to g4 and now the usual line
continues with the move bishop to e2
e6
castle on the king side bishop to e7
s3
bishop to f5
a3
castle on the king side bishop to v3 and
now
very much familiar plan
yep you got it it's knight capture c3 b
capture c3 and knight to a5 planning is
to play the move c5 as quickly as
possible
and get a very comfortable game
so let's look at the main line where
white captures the knight
after knight captures and pawn captures
white's idea is to play the move c3 and
this move is very much justified because
not only this knight is misplaced but
this pawn is a clear target for the
white
well that's the downside the good side
is
it's not easy to capture this phone
and you will see in upcoming games that
to get this pawn white has to pay a
heavy price
the move i'm going to recommend is you
play the move g6
which is a quite unknown territory and
not many white players will feel
comfortable about it
and to understand this i want to show
you three different games where white
tried different kind of setups and all
miserably fails
so in the first game my opponent
responded with the move bishop to b5 i
responded with the move bishop to d7 and
now he played the move queen to e2 so as
usual targeting the e4 pawn no matter i
played the move a6 and here if bishop
goes to the c4 then knight to a5 is a
very strong move so my opponent
responded here with the move bishop to
a4
but this is a typical trap where capture
the e5
bomb if d captures e5 then bishop
captures bishop so the obvious move is
bishop captures bishop afterwards we are
going to save overnight with knight
captures d7
the following line continues with the
move queen captures e4 attacking b7 but
after c6
knight to f3 bishop to g7 castle on the
king's side and castle on the king side
i think black is very very comfortably
placed
the game continues with the move rook to
e1 attacking the e7
i defended with the move rook to e8 and
now
he played the move bishop to g5
so you can see this is one of the most
aggressive line in the setup well no
matter we can do a counter attack with
the move queen to b6
my opponent defended here with the move
queen to c2 afterwards the typical break
in the center yup it's e5
the game continues with the move d
catches e5 and knight captures e5 knight
captures e5 bishop captures e5 and rook
to d1
it looks like white is doing very good
but after black's next move that is
queen to e5
if fight is not careful then he's about
to lose a pawn
in the game he tried to defend with the
move a3 but he completely missed my next
shot that is
bishop captures s2
king captures h2 row captures rook row
captures rook and queen captures g5 not
only regaining a piece but emerge with a
clear pawn advantage
in the second game my opponent tried the
obvious looking move that is bishop to
e3
his idea is when i play the move bishop
to g7 he wants to play the move queen to
d2
castle on the queen side and then
quickly launch a devastating attack on
my king
well first of all i stop him castling on
the queen side via the queen to d5
and now if y respond with the moon
knight to e2 then there will be a
transposition of the knight to e2 line
so the another independent move which my
opponent try over here is
c4
against this i'm recommending that you
should definitely exchange the queen
with the move queen to e5
the simple reason is after queen
captures and knight captures
we are going to undermine the spawn
chain with the move c5
the game continues with the move b4 so
my opponent is gaining tremendous space
on the queen side no matter it's not as
dangerous as this looks i calmly played
knight to c6
he became more aggressive with the move
b4 which is a minor mistake i come back
again with the moon knight to e5 and now
he played the move rook to c1 so his
idea is to deal off his knight to the e2
so the c4 pawn doesn't hang
well in certain condition you have to
play your typical break and that is what
i played over here the move is
c5
quickly undermining the white pawn chain
after the long thinking my opponent
captured this pawn with n percent
and i recapture with the knight
he continued with the moon knight to e2
i responded with the move bishop to f5
he played the move knight to g3 and now
the move of the game that is
castle on the queen side
i think at this point he realized that
he is in a danger of losing this game
the simple reason is d4 pawn will be a
goner in the long run
he continued with the move group to d1
and i follow a very simple plan i just
want to double up my rook on the t file
seeing that he can no way defend on d4
pawn he come out with the following move
order he played knight captures bishop
and after pawn captures
he played the move h3
my opponent's idea was that when i try
to get the d pawn with the rook to d8
idea then he can hit back my f5 pawn
with the moon
g4 no matter i continue with the move
bishop captures e5
he played g captures f5 and after the
following order bishop catches bishop
bishop captures bishop
knight captures bishop he responded with
the move bishop to g2
in fact is a big blunder
before we go on i want you to pause this
position
and find out a continuation which can
give winning edge to the black
okay i hope you find this move that is
e3
tremendous moon
thing is when white recaptures the pawn
you have this amazing sequence starting
with the knight to c2 check
king to e2 rogue captures rook rogue
captures rook rope captures rook and
when finally king captures the piece
then we have this
lethal check which will grab the piece
the last and the final aggressive move
has been played is knight to e2
which has a very simple idea that when
you played the move bishop to g7
white respond with the move knight to g3
so straight away concentrating on the
weak e4 square
well no matter we can easily defend this
pawn with the move queen to d5
my opponent responded with the move
queen to c2 attacking one more time and
i defended one more time with the move
bishop to f5
so as i told you earlier it's very hard
for white to get this pawn
my opponent continued here with the move
bishop to e3 and i responded very
energetically with the move f6 it's very
important for black to undermine the
white pawn chain before white dull of
his all piece
he captured on f6 i recapture with the
bishop
in the view of queen captures a2 my
opponent cannot cast from the queen side
so he switch switches plan and goes back
on the king side with the move order
bishop to e2
now watching white is playing very
passive moves i decided to race the war
flag with the moon castle on the queen
side
my opponent happily accepted so he
castle short
and now i put my king on the b8 so very
safe
he get aggressive with the move b4 which
is a very natural
throwing pawn storms no matter i
continue with the move e5 hitting in the
center
and here he made a critical error he
played the move b5 which turns out very
very bad for him
i continue with the move e captures d4
and now he made the second mistake by
playing the move rook f to d1
it's okay it's pinning that pawn but the
major problem is now black has this
amazing resource that is
queen to c5 pinning the c3 pawn and the
same time creating a threat of capturing
the bishop
white doesn't have anything left except
capturing the knight afterwards i
capture his bishop and the game
continues with the move knight captures
f5 pawn catches f2 king to f1 and
finally capturing a piece
so you can already see after all this
moves black opt in a very good position
it has a threatening pawns in the center
seeing that my opponent tried to get rid
of some major piece so he exchanged a
pair of rooks and offered the second one
which i happily accepted
and after that i just captured the c6
pawn
it's okay white can grab the f2 pawn but
after
queen capture c3
white has a huge huge problems
seeing nothing better my opponent tried
to exchange some queen trade
but after bishop to d4 check king to f1
and queen to e3
white is almost on the verge of losing
the game
he tried bishop h5
but this is not sufficient
queen check and now
simple but very effective move
queen captures h2
and he just resign at this point
that's all folks i hope with this
wonderful analysis you can confidently
meet the move d4
well thank you for watching this
and i meet you in my next sideline
episode that is d3 bye